[Music]
what's going on guys is it just me or
does it seem to be more and more remakes
these days every time it turn around
there's a new bender or a warmed-over a
Robocop staring me in the face but this
isn't a new phenomenon remakes have been
a part of Hollywood's DNA since the very
beginning and some of them are your
favorite movies I know right so today
we're gonna find some of the more
obscure ones in an episode that we call
that was a remake let's start with the
latest remake hitting the theaters the
Magnificent Seven any film school
student can tell you that the original
Magnificent Seven is just an
Americanized remake of one of the
greatest movies ever made Akira
Kurosawa's Seven Samurai but this wasn't
the only Western to borrow from Kurosawa
knew Sergio Leone's legendary a fistful
of dollars was essentially a remake of
Kurosawa's film Yojimbo so much so that
Leone had to pony up some cash when he
was sued for copying it in the end
Kurosawa and Leone went on to be
recognized as two of the greatest
directors ever and A Fistful of Dollars
launched the film career of Clint
Eastwood see mime you don't like people
laughing it's the crazy idea you're
laughing at him if you watch the show
you know how much I love my mom and when
I'm not making her watch terribly
uncomfortable movies here in the studio
she loves watching her favorite movie of
all time The Wizard of Oz one of the
greatest movies ever made but did you
know that that's a remake - yeah right
it is the first Wizard of Oz was a
silent film not even a talkie and it was
written directed produced by and starred
the timeless Larry Semon you know
Chaplin Garbo Buster Keaton and Larry
Semon
anyway in this version the Tin Man
scarecrow and lion aren't really helping
Dorothy on her quest as much as they're
hitting on her they're courting her on
her 18th birthday that is 100% true
it's the Tin Man scarecrow and lion and
a barely legal Dorothy you know what
that's not really Wizard of Oz that's
this isn't Wizard of Oz a xxx parity one
of the most successful movie spies this
side of James Bond
is Jason Bourne did you know that the
first movie The Bourne Identity is a
remake I did not know that before I did
research for this episode yeah it's a
remake of a 1988 TV movie starring
Richard Chamberlain and Jaclyn Smith
let's just take a look I think was born
born you're convinced general Compton
the born was also responsible for the
assassination of ambassador Leland I am
just like Jason Bourne I don't remember
what just happened because I fell asleep
that movie is three hours long and it
may be more true to the Robert Ludlum
novel but it just doesn't hold up how
can you possibly top the excitement of
early 2000s Matt Damon hey 80s Bourne
Identity give me a call when you get
Moby and Run Lola Run on board
let's talk comedy remakes one of the
most beloved comedies of all time is
1980s airplane I know what you're
thinking airplane a remake surely you
can't be serious see what I did there
but airplane is essentially a
word-for-word remake of 1957 disaster
film called zero hour
the main difference zero hour plays a
completely straight same dialogue no
jokes
it's the kind of melodramatic movie that
was just begging for the Zucker Brothers
Abrams treatment you're been the kind of
kid before no sir I've never been
nothing at playing me for you ever been
in the cockpit before no sir I've never
been up in a plane before never seen a
grown man naked so zero hour is
basically the same movie as airplane
without the jokes kind of like how
Zoolander 2 is to Zoolander there have
been countless horror makes Halloween
Nightmare on Elm Street Friday the 13th
but enough of those disappointing ones
I'd like to talk about a great one the
thing and I'm not talking about the 2011
remake of John Carpenter's The Thing I'm
talking about the original John
Carpenter movie fun fact
carpenters the thing came out two weeks
after ET and was a flop people wanted to
see the loveable healing alien ouch
and not john carpenter's nightmare
aliens which features some of the most
awesome / gruesome practical effects of
all time
did you know is a remake of 1951 s the
thing from another world
carpenter loved that movie so much he
didn't just remake it he featured it in
his own breakthrough hit 1978 s
Halloween fYI the thing is the second in
what I call the John Carpenter Kurt
Russell trilogy featuring escape from
New York the thing and Big Trouble in
Little China some may argue the best
trilogy of all time you know what
name a trilogy that's better in the
comments below
you're probably naming a lot of
trilogies it's well known that Martin
Scorsese's The Departed is a faithful
remake of the Hong Kong film Infernal
Affairs
but there's another crime film that you
might not know is a remake Michael
Mann's Heat
that's right man remade a 1988 movie
called la take down complete with the
same characters the same plot even some
of the same scenes you see me doing
thrill-seeker liquor store holdups with
a born to lose tattoo on my chest no
right you see me doing thrill-seeker
liquor store holdups would have born to
lose tattoo on my chest no I do not
right
usually when you completely steal an
idea and remake it the lawsuits start
flying people love to sue in Hollywood
but it turns out that Michael Mann took
the source material from his most
trusted collaborator himself yep
Michael Mann remade one of his own
lesser-known movies as a brand new movie
and turned it into a modern classic see
M night Shyamalan - Last Airbender there
may be hope for you yet you know there's
there's no hope for that one I was
terrible movie and finally we arrived at
Arnold Schwarzenegger the king of 80s
and 90s action but did you know that one
of his biggest and best movies was a
remake True Lies that's not a lie yes
the James Cameron classic is a remake of
the 1991 French comedy la po tau
starring no one you've ever heard of not
even Gerard Depardieu is in that and
directed by some French dude the French
version was well received but had none
of the stuff you love from James
Cameron's movie no Arnold no Tom Arnold
no badass Charlton Heston with an
eyepatch no Jamie Lee Curtis dance and
worst of all no awesome one-liner
you're fired here's a not true lie the
original version of this movie was
better get it that was just a lie I
think wait what's it what is a true lie
I like doesn't make sense
that's a total oxymoron title at movies
giving me an aneurysm so those are some
of our favorite remakes that were kind
of surprised to find out our remakes
what did we not mention what are some
movies that you were surprised have been
made before let us know in the comments
section below we want to know also do
you think you have what it takes to be
an official screen junkie we're looking
for one of you to join us right here as
part of our new screen junkies news team
go to SJ dot plus slash new junkie to
find out how you can submit for a chance
to join all of us right here at screen
junkies boom dreams are coming true
thanks for watching I'm how run to get
me up on Twitter bye bye hey guys did
you know that this end card works with
your phone now I know right click the
boxes below to watch more screen junkies
videos and click the screen junkies logo
to subscribe and get this show honest
trailers movie fights and more